hello and welcome to this video playing
grandmaster medela 2019
let me check no name
okay so knight f3 here
yeah what do i do here let's go for the
bogo um
i fixed the number uh the
the game number the game before i forgot
to
up the counter
one so there's no four nine four five on
the video
um anyway so let's play this game
and i got black i had three white games
in a row before
it was surprising
usually it's oops
it's um just alternating
quite evenly alternating
so queen a5 it's probably just not
really doing much
well maybe it's probably also not
hurting much
at the end of the day i will probably
build up some kind of hedgehog
okay
okay rook g8
now i could trade on c3 but it's not
really
it doesn't look very desirable
so just let's just
go back and go for that hedgehog
with queen c7 rook b8 and so on
the somewhat uncommon feature
of this um coming hedgehog formation is
that
i have a dark squared bishop and white
um does not and this is not so easy for
white to handle because often in the
um play against a hedgehog you want to
win want to gain more space
moves like f4 for example and i mean it
seems like he's preparing this
but the move f4 also weakens
quite a bit the dark squares so this is
an interesting
way to play this is featured in my
2015 book on the nimzo
so yeah he has weakened his dark squares
quite a bit it's k
it can still be good for white don't get
me wrong but
it's um somewhat different
type of hedgehog okay um
i wonder if i should play d6 or not
you could argue about moves like h5h4
don't know tough one
this is a bit lame d6
bishop d7
f5 i go knight e5
interesting okay
yeah okay he wants to increase the
pressure here on
e6 after f5
so let's go back f5 bishop f6
it should be okay
maybe here queen c5 okay
making the knight a bit more difficult
to move
okay
b5 is not yet working
maybe maybe i can be annoying with this
move
now b5 maybe b5 take sticks
is there a reason why that shouldn't
work i don't know let's play it i don't
have
that much time maybe e5
but i can maybe even take that
okay i did not see that move coming
interesting
so i cannot take now because my queen is
hanging
i can do this and probably it's also
what i should do
so now
this one where is he going with the
queen so
here queen b6 i can go
the queen has very few squares
okay i have to speed up
i could of course continue to chase the
queen but
i thought that this should be good for
me
the time situation is of course a little
bit problematic but
i will see a particular reason for
making a draw other than the time
i wonder about the knight on f8 if if
knight h7 f6 could be played somehow
activated
this is getting more interesting with
the bishop on g2
yeah i may have saw that move is there a
tactic or something
okay let's do it there must be yeah
that must have been the idea otherwise
it makes no sense at all
i have bishop c5
this one
what is he doing now where is he going
queen eighth although this one i didn't
see that one
okay
no pre-move
this is increment it's really important
so i'm not just going to lose on time
so this is reasonably safe
wow tough one there tough game i don't
know what
i don't really know what's going on
there so
let's check a little bit so
probably um start here i don't know i
felt this is
equal i mean
i think i'm quite solid here you cannot
easily play f5 and so on so
yeah okay the computer is at least
initially agreeing
so queen b4 and i can just take me
through that silly
that's so good why not just grab b3
that's totally terrible i mean it's not
one pawn it's the whole game
look look at those damn okay i played b5
he played this rook b8 takes
and ba just wins
okay
we we almost had the same thing yeah
so here
yeah i was thinking he recaptures but
then rookie 8 traps the queen okay
that was pretty bad way to play but we
get something
and that's not as good right
and now it now it turned totally crazy
d5
took and i can just take on d5 okay
now i was i was quite
quite shocked at the moment bishop takes
i was worried about this move
here but i can't take on a4
okay so there are many many tactical
mistakes there bishop c5 however
does not seem to lose at least and now
king f8 was winning
and now i couldn't do it so this
this and now there's some kind of draw
if you place rook
one to d2
yeah to keep attacking the queen
i have no good way here so i have to be
on that rook
and then it's a weird kind of perpetual
on the queen
odd he took and this is probably not so
good right
okay take uh a5 silts here still seems
to be okay
if he gets to a6
yeah i mean it's it's it's rather
logical that you should play if
a5 as long as you can after this it's
over
i'm i'm protecting the bishop
and at the same time i'm twice on that
square so
the pawn is not going anywhere and then
you can start to convert
so still a5 is a lot better
i would have thought it should still
still should still win somehow
six bishops is seven yeah i'm not sure
the depth the depth here is probably not
uh sufficient to completely
clarify this f takes queen takes a6
f takes g5 queen takes e5
a6 bishop c7 queen f2
bishop b8 and now
yeah i have no clue anyway i have to run
guys thanks for
watching this video bye bye